and today we're continuing our time
management master class with news
you can use we've all been worrying more
this year
oh my god all i do is worry
stress worry but how do you deal with
that
i don't want to sit there i want
like actionable help and the new york
times suggests
making time to worry to get back to the
rest of your day
they say scheduling 15 minutes to
freestyle worry and then get over it
rip the anxiety band-aid off and they
also suggest
resetting with a special type of
breathing
i do agree with that see i have breathe
written on my arm and guess what i still
forget
you breathe in rocking forward and you
breathe out
rocking back this is me normally
all right so they call this rock and
roll breathing
all right but i prefer van inhaling
if mornings are more of your stumbling
block
then this one really speaks to me i have
to say
try waking up with the sun or at least
a mini fake one yahoo news reports
people are turning to sunrise light
alarm clocks to help get out of bed
easier
you set when you want the sun to rise
and then it slowly brightens to wake you
up
um or you could just use nature alarms
clock which is my children
um although my kids are old enough now
that they
totally sleep in past when we're all
supposed to that's the irony parents
you literally wake up at 4am which i've
always done for work anyway but it never
gets any easier you get up at 4am and
then the minute your kids start to be
able to sleep till eight
they gotta get up at six for school it
is sadistic
my child finally wants to be lazy and
sleep in and you make me get up and get
out
it's like you never get off the hamster
wheel
one way some parents approached time
management during
at-home learning was a daily schedule
like this color-coded one that went
viral on social media
that is not how it's gone
for me and my life and i'm just
wondering
you color-coded wonder how do you do it
and today.com says that tons of other
parents are actually feeling apparently
the same way
i am and sharing their more realistic
schedules like this one from lawyer
kelly
[Music]